welcome back to me rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse in Black Widow released a new
special look trailer that gives us way
more footage of the villain taskmaster
who's like monkey see monkey moves gives
us some insight on who this mystery man
or woman could be or at least who
they're lifting with let's break down
this trailer shot by shop for all the
visual clues and Russian tattoos that
you might have missed that could explain
how this movie will connect to the MCU
as it kicks off base Bor be sure to
check out my breakdown of the first
trailer back in December and spoiler
warning the case in this video I predict
it too much here we go Natasha my sister
after all this time what brings you home
okay this special look opens with a shot
of a city you look closely that looks
like Natasha Romanov in a sniper
position on the roof there now the first
trailer footage was set largely in
Budapest lorries I'm pretty sure this
city is Tel Aviv there was that Israeli
travel document barely visible in the
previous trailer we see the before and
after of Natasha's confrontation with
the Alena Belova Natasha recovers a gun
that she kept hidden guns don't kill
people
Natasha leaving loaded firearms in
foreign cities all over the world kills
people moving on I was trying to do
something doing
[Music]
any more than just a trained killer
you're fooling yourself we're still both
trained killers Natasha tells you Lena
that she's on the run holding out this
red glowing object and we have seen SEC
photos of Natasha waiting through a pond
with this thing a general red glow is
kind of a recurring color in this film
you'll notice the other Black Widow
agents of a similar red glowing thing on
them interesting Lee Natasha's widow's
bite gauntlet charge is red not blue as
it normally is let me know what you
think this is all about in the comments
below
Jelena's sealian implodes as other
assassins drop in Florence pews Russian
accent also drops a bit we're still both
trained killers killers
come on flow at least elizabeth Olsen
waited a full movie to drop her Russian
accent yeah well maybe Alena is
deliberately switching to an American
accent mid-sentence here as a dig at
Natasha who did drop her Russian accent
as a way to show Natasha that you can
talk like an American Avenger but you
can't take the Russia out of the widow
next clip
as we
this section shows us more of Alexi
Shostak of red Guardian now it's not
clear if he's breaking out of a Russian
prison or in some kind of prison fight
behind them there does appear to be a
bunch of men trapped in another cage
segment suggesting maybe this is a riot
where the guards got caged up and that's
how Alexi breaks out he again shows off
his enhanced strength you twist this
guy's arm tosses him like he's nothing
maybe Alexi could have been given a
knockoff version of CAP Super Soldier
Serum it was good to see some more
action from Rachel basses character
milena and she does guys remove the
Black Widow go to scissor tackles does
it on taskmaster here and that appears
to be rent guardian at their feet in the
foreground
maybe Alexi gave Molina and assist
because one-on-one
taskmaster can mirror you perfectly
unbeatable so it takes two on one to
take them down
now Molina fighting taskmaster here
seems to debunk the theory that Molina
is herself taskmaster but I still think
there's more to her character than the
trailers are letting on moving on big
together again ok we gonna have a look
at this fun moment with Alexi squeezing
back into his Captain America style red
Guardian suit and I will again remind
you here that Yelena is wearing the same
vest at natasha shows up wearing an
infinity war now this movie story will
be set partially at least in the period
between Civil War and infinity war so
there's got to be some wild story about
how NAT ended up in that best my rogue
theory of the moment is that Yelena
could get facial reconstructive surgery
to look like Natasha Romanov and take
her place for the events of infinity war
in endgame and that it is Elena who dies
on Boromir and Natasha could still be
alive it's not too crazy remember an
endgame red skull greeted her as I've
had an Ivan was a name she didn't
recognize maybe making this [ __ ] up
I don't think so I could he know as your
daddy's name I didn't which is a bit
weird because there was a deleted scene
in Civil War written and directed by the
same people who did in game where
Natasha talked about mind and her
parents graves after everything happened
shield during my little hiatus I went
back to Russia and tried to find my
parents
two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence I pulled some weeds and left some
flowers over things let's also look too
deeply at Alexei Seine water wait
no assuming he is the Russian equivalent
to Captain America maybe Alexei also
spent a period of his life plunged into
icy water and let's move on with the
rest of the trailer
new dummies
I'm done running from my past
past masters armored tank truck tears up
the streets of Budapest to see more
shots of the Black Widow agents training
and pursuing it Natasha throughout the
streets
maybe after Natasha went rogue with cap
and civil war that coulda led all of the
world governments to turn on her and try
to take her out and then there's the
villain taskmaster in that bridge shot
that was shown at comicon taskmaster in
the comics is Tony masters who can
perfectly mirror any warriors combat
style just by watching them fight just
like how if nerds like us watching
Natasha scissor tackle enough times we
can do it too and the previous footage
taskmaster used a bow and arrow
suggesting that he could have been
mirroring combat styles of Clint Barton
here taskmaster uses a shield and
backhand blazed it like we've seen Steve
Rogers do and if you look closely you
can also see taskmaster swinging on a
tether I don't like doing an impression
of spider-man well taskmaster is a
pretty cool villain I hope he makes it
through to future films but if he is a
one-and-done villain all of those hints
of who is this guy makes me think it'll
be revealed as a woman like Elena who
does mirror
Natasha's moves in that kitchen fight
but I'm also still clinging on to the
theory that this could be revealed as
Clint Barton
maybe with Thunderbolt Ross exploiting
Clint's post-civil war legal troubles
and separating him from his family
unless Clint were to carry out a mission
for him in Budapest you'll notice that
taskmaster uses a sword here which is
similar to the sword that Clint used as
his Ronin assassin identity in endgame
and his battle here with Natasha would
add even more greater emotional weight
to their reunion and endgame and that
reunion could be what the voiceover and
the additional feature Rhett was
referring to one thing's for sure before
I move on there's another great shot of
Natasha's big die from that collapsing
debris wondering what she's jumping from
what what kind of structure would be
that high up would we be looking at a
Helicarrier as it explodes think about
that as we move on to the final clip
[Music]
the hell is that guy
okay here Natasha fights some of the
other Black Widow agents and notice the
shutters on the far right of this room
this room is the same mysterious setting
that we saw in the previous trailer that
room with the chessboard and projector
slides and weird screens showing city
maps that featurette also had a
behind-the-scenes production shot I'm
Natasha fighting in this location the
reverse angle that shows a bust on the
desk and a painting some mysterious
figure I was thinking this could be some
kind of person from Russian history
maybe like I've been the terrible but I
wasn't able to confirm it and then
lastly we get Natasha vs. taskmaster on
bridge he shoots him right in the damn
face but his mask is bulletproof
I don't think she knew that though and
then they both live to their feet
simultaneously reflecting taskmasters
mirror moves and a really cool detail
here if you look closely in the
reflection of taskmasters visor you can
see a Natasha's face reflected back who
do you think taskmaster is Hamid down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at ei vas and
follow new rock stars on social media
and subscribe to me rock stars on
YouTube for breakdowns of everything you
love also be sure to check out our new
Q&A series the big question that's one
we're Philip and I give you too much
information about how terrifying these
Marvel characters would be in the real
world because believe it or not Black
Widow is in the real world too just
probably your next-door neighbor but if
you work for a government agency you do
not get into relationship with her the
KGB will end up having to extract you
and you'll just have to grocery shop in
Moscow where they have one kind of
toothpaste see you next time
[Music]